foreign
why did that feel so good
in case you haven't noticed people are
feeling more stressed and angry these
days
according to gallup's Global emotion
report more than one in four experience
sadness and slightly fewer experienced
anger so what can we do about it well
you can try meditation but this works
too
I visited her lab to find out more about
the roles that aggression plays in our
lives welcome to the lab this is way
nicer than either of our labs in grad
school I think so too Anna Gordon and I
did our phds in neurobiology together
and now she runs a lab here at Princeton
here you go thank you one part of her
research is decoding how the brain
creates that feel-good energy we
experience at The Rage Cage that energy
has to do with rewards animals that are
more aggressive to a point right they
basically can accrue more resources they
have more territory which means more
food which means more access to females
in this experiment a male Mouse learns
that when he pokes his nose into one of
these two holes at the back of this box
he can either choose between sex or
aggression when he opts for aggression a
submissive Mouse drops into the box the
fight is fixed and the dominant Mouse is
conditioned to know he'll win he'll
choose aggression unless the other Mouse
starts fighting back we know that they
get a surge of dopamine at the end of a
fight it's a little bit unclear about
what this dopamine has to do with the
action of the fighting or whether the
outcome so that way we felt so good at
The Rage Cage I mean I was definitely
experiencing a surge of dopamine I don't
know about you that natural high
incentivizes mice and humans to go back
for more animals evolve to do this
because aggression is very important for
survival there are two flavors of
aggression proactive aggression is When
Animals seek out aggression just like in
the nose poking experiment this
aggression tends to have a goal like
expanding your territory or relieving
stress by breaking stuff then there's
reactive aggression this is the
aggression where you say something
terrible to me and I I punch you in the
face it's a response to a threat like
when your territory is infiltrated
territory and aggression kind of go hand
in hand so when animals cross into other
parts of the territory they might change
their aggression levels annequate uses
this wheel to track the relationship
between territory aggression and rank so
mice really like to pee and they create
these territorial marks unclaimed
territory doesn't always exist so the
mouse has the decision to make
especially if he's not dominant so our
hypothesis is that when he's in his home
he feels less anxiety and he's in the
territory of others he feels more
anxiety I can relate to that yeah
exactly but we don't yet know what he's
feeling when he's in expansion mode in
the new territory that's important
because how you're feeling affects
aggression level to whether you're a
mouse or a human when the non-dominant
mouse stays put there's more activity in
certain neurons that are anxiety
inducing these act almost like a break
they lower the activity of the
hypothalamus a region that drives
aggression in extreme situations this
break completely goes off and mice feel
overly confident you get something
called septal Rage which is animals that
get hyper aggressive but under more
normal conditions we think there's
something a little bit more nuanced
happening where it's not just like a
non-off switch this brain Network helps
animals figure out what the best course
of action is given their chances of
coming out on top turn on aggression or
just back away neuroscientists used to
think that these aggression levels were
hardwired or kind of preset but in fact
there's a lot of plasticity they're
changing all the time as a function of
your experience which makes sense since
aggression is supposed to improve our
chances of survival and part of that
hinges on adapting after the lab tour I
sat down with anagram to talk more about
what kinds of situations making more
prone to aggression and what we can do
about it stress can make you kind of
very overreactive to certain kinds of
cues in your environment
loud sounds loud noises those are the
things that promote this kind of
reactive aggression as opposed to the
sort of cold aggression seeking behavior
that we talked about in the lab she told
me that understanding what triggers
aggression can help us come up with ways
to prevent unnecessary violence either
with medication or behavioral
interventions so we went to our Rage
Cage we did is that a good way to deal
with anger management I think for some
people it might work in the very short
term
but it's definitely not a long-term
solution overall you'd probably be
better off if you steered yourself into
a slightly calmer Pursuit that could
mean meditation therapy or journaling
learning when and how to defend yourself
is also important in her experiments
myself learned to defend themselves also
sought out more social interactions and
treats like sugar water aggression I
would say is about 25 to 50 heritable so
it's determined by your genes which
means the other sort of half of
aggression is you know based on your
experience so aggression kind of begets
aggression